good afternoon everyone um indeed today
i would like to present this new python
package for deduplication i called it
deduplipi
um
and before i start i indeed want to give
a bit direction about myself so born and
raised in the netherlands um i studied
physics
and then i started working for ing bank
11 years ago i had various modeling
positions and yeah in the last years i
mainly focus on detecting money
laundering and other types of financial
economic crime in
transactions and this is how i started
to to work on the interesting topic of
deduplication
before we jump to the package i would
like to first explain you a bit about
what the duplication
means
the task of deduplication is basically
to identify the single real world entity
from different notations
and another word or for deduplication is
entity resolution
on the screen you see
11
company names in different
representations but they are not 11
different companies actually when you
apply deduplication you see that there
are basically three different companies
so this is what humans are very good at
and what's also useful to
let computers do
there are basically two challenges when
it comes to deduplication
the first challenge is how do we compare
two strings
the most well-known additives the most
well-known string similarity metric is
the left-line edit distance this is
basically that the number of changes you
need to make to one string to transform
it to into the other string
and then um that is a measure of string
similarity
um
however
a different entity can have a smaller
levenshtein distance
than for a different notation of the
same entity let me show you this with an
example so here you see the pair airbus
and airbnb you want to compare them
and as you can see you need to change
two characters to transform airbus into
airbnb so they're added distances too
and it's a different company obviously
if you look at the second case there is
the airbus group se and airbus
this has a larger added distance so the
string similarity metric is larger
or the the distance metric is larger so
basically if you look at the the
characters only the second pair is more
dissimilar than the first pair however
the second pair is
the same company the airplane
manufacturer and the first pair are
really different companies
so basically you cannot choose a string
similarity metric set the threshold and
say
above or below the thresholds
the representations belong to the same
entity and vice versa
so the first challenge is how do we
compare two strings
the second challenge in deduplication is
what comparisons are you going to make
if you would naively compare every
string with every other string in the
data set
the you get an n squared problem the
number of comparisons blow up and it's
not computational computationally
feasible to
do all the calculations so if you have n
strings then the number of comparisons
becomes n times n minus one over two
let's let's take an example uh spotify
has 70 million tracks and there are
duplicates in it these are not really
the same tracks but these are
variations in orchestra for example for
classical music or they are remixes etc
if you would deduplicate this data set
with all the possible comparisons you
can make you would end up with a number
of comparisons that is just unfeasible
to calculate
so the second challenge in the
duplication is to select which
comparison you need to make in a smart
way
entity resolution or duplication has
drawn a lot of intentions from academia
as if you type entity resolution in
google scholar you find like 11 000
articles
and
even over the last years you still see
new articles popping up
lately mainly in the with the
application of deep learning
still i thought that i could add
something to this page so i created the
package deductly pipe
the idea of the dupli-pie is that it's a
deduplication package that works out of
the box so you can
just create an instance
fit it and predict it just as any other
scikit-learn model
however the reason why i created this is
this is that i wanted to be able to
tweak and tune some advanced settings
for the more experienced users
i work in a bank we have very big data
and sometimes we just need to be able to
tune things because of the large data
that we deal with
and i couldn't find that yet in the
packages that were available
let me show you how the dupli pie solves
the two challenges include application
that i mentioned earlier
first of all this n squared problem
most if not all deduplication approaches
first apply blocking to the data
and then you only compare the pairs that
fall into the same block
let me show you how this works so the
first step is that you apply a large
list of blocking rules to the data
and these blocking rules can be things
like the same first word or the same
first three characters the same integers
etc there is a whole bunch of blocking
rules implemented in the dupli pi and in
principle you don't need to worry about
that it happens all underneath
then the dupli pie uses a so-called
greedy set cover algorithm to take the
smallest set of blocking rules that
maximizes the inclusion of the positive
training labels so it's basically the
most efficient set of blocking rules
that you should use for comparing all
the individual
representations
then we only compare the pairs within
the same blocks and thereby we reduce
the number of comparisons by a lot
so if you look on the right side of this
slide you see a data set that i created
myself based on stocks 50 companies
eurostoxx 15
companies
and if you would naively compare
everything with everything then the
amber shaded region
would all have to be compared
if you apply a blocking rule let's say
the first word so you only compare pairs
where both representations share the
same first words then only a fraction of
it
the the much smaller region you see on
the screen has to be compared
and the dupli by allows you to easily
add your own blocking goals or to choose
your own blocking rules
and that is say something that i really
needed for the problems i work with
remember that the second challenge in
the duplication was how to compare two
strings
and the dupli pi solves this problem
with a very simple logistic regression
model that is trained on features that
are the similarity metrics
so in the dupli pi we use the fuzzy
rusty package it's it's a package on
pipeline
that implements a lot of string
similarity metrics so for all the pairs
that we found during the blocking stage
of the of the process we calculate a
bunch of string similarity metrics so
you see here ing bank ing bank and v
that's a pair
and then you calculate a bunch of string
similarity matrix and you do that for
all the pairs in your data
well as i mentioned i i think it's
important that the more experienced
users can choose their own settings so
you can also apply your own similarity
metrics
and that is very simple the only thing
you need to do is create a function that
takes two strings and outputs a number
so here you see an example
let's say that you want to
include as a feature whether or not the
first word of two
representations match perfectly
then you can implement it yourself like
this and add it to the duplicate
instance
so at this stage we have per pair we
have a
number of
string similarity metrics and these are
then used as features for a logistic
regression model that is trained on
these that is trained to predict whether
a pair is a metronome
and for this i use psychic learning
under the hood because that is like a
perfect implementation
as a user you can also choose to
include interaction features
and with that you can
scikit learn basically includes the
products of all the individual string
similarity metrics we then apply l1
regularization to make sure that you
don't overfit and basically thereby
apply a feature selection
so this way we score all the pairs
within the blocks and
go to the next step
so how do we how do we train this uh
classification model
you could uh take a bunch of
of data samples or a data sample and
then
label all the combinations in there or
so but that's a lot of work and most
often
the majority of the pairs are not a
match
so that's the reason why we use active
learning here
as implemented by the modal package
um in active learning you create an
interactive session where the user
enters for each pair that is presented
whether it is a match or not
and it's this is a very efficient way to
collect training data
and
quickly have a trained model
so how it works you present all the
pairs that you found in your blocking
stage
and then
the model is applied to the data and
then the
data sample so the pair in this case
that the model is most uncertain about
is presented to the user the user then
gives a yes or no whether it's a match
or not that data point is added to the
training data the model is retrained and
the process continues and you continue
doing that until you have a converged
model
and this
generally with the dupli by you have a
converged model in like about 20 30 of
these steps it goes really fast
the question then is how does how does
the dupli by or modal i should say how
does it measure the uncertainty and
that's actually pretty simple it's just
one minus the probability of the most
probable class
so let me show that in this
in this little plot there are three data
points the amber dots indicate the data
points and the prediction of the model
and as you can see the most left and the
most right data points there is a small
uncertainty so there is the the score is
close to close to one
but the point in the middle has a much
larger uncertainty so when you do active
learning this will be the data point
that will be presented to the user and
the user should then give input whether
it's a
it's a zero or a one whether it's a
match or not
let's have a look how this active
learning works on a um yeah
a data set and for this we use the north
carolina voter registry data set it's a
data set that is more often used for
deduplication and is provided by
professor erhard
the data set consists of three columns
the name the suburb and the postcode
and there are a lot of duplicates in it
as you can see the first two are most
likely duplicates there are two
representations of the same person
so chemical thomas is written in in two
different ways here
then he lives in charlotte suburb and
there is also a typo and there's a g
instead of a nine or an ocr error i
don't know what the sources of this data
and the task is here to
identify which rows belong to each other
which rows belong to the same
real world entity and person in this
case
so let's have a look how this
uncertainty
evolves over the training of the d
duplicate instance
here we look at an uncertainty
map on the horizontal axis you see the
similarity of the names and on the
vertical axis you see the similarity of
the suburbs because i wanted to create a
two-dimensional plot i could only use
two columns and just one
similarity metric per per column
then on the bottom left you see the
dissimilar names and the dissimilar
suburbs so these are the cases where
most likely it's not a match
and on the top right you see the more
similar names and the more similar
suburbs so there's a larger probability
that
the bear is image
then the colors indicate the uncertainty
so on the bottom left you see a lot of
green they're very low uncertainty and
that is logical because if there is no
similarity in the name and no similarity
in the suburb it's most likely not image
on the top right you see that there is
much there are much less dots but
there's a lot of white and that is just
because there are not so many matches in
the data
but there you also see some some
greenish colors here
and that's also logical because if there
is very large similarity in both the
names and the suburbs it's most likely a
match
and in the region in between you see a
lot of red so there is the high
uncertainty so these are the pairs that
will be presented to the user
this is the uncertainty heat map after
two label pairs
then the
duplify will present the most
uncertain pair to the user and the user
needs to enter whether it's a match or
not and the parent is presented is shown
here in the in the plot
so in this case i would say this this is
a match although there are some typos in
it after four pairs
the plot looks like this and if you
continue labeling you see over time
that the the area of the red area so the
uncertain area gets much smaller and
after 50 labeled pairs the mole is
converged
so now you see that really on the bottom
left of course it's a lot of green so
there is no uncertainty these are just
no patches and on the top right you see
there is also a good green area
indicating that the model is not unsure
so it's sure about the
positive
the matches of the pairs
okay so we first started with the
blocking stage then within the blocks we
calculate the similarities of the pairs
they are using this interactive learning
and the next thing that we do is that we
are going to create a network of pairs
and probabilities
for this we use network x
and
in this graph that we create every node
is a representation it's basically a row
in our data set and every edge between
the nodes is the
is the pair that is that is scored and
the edge weights the numbers you see
in the lines is the probability that was
output by the logistic regression model
the first thing after creating this
network that we do is
we apply the connected components
algorithm and the connected components
algorithm
um
distinguishes the subgraphs in the graph
where every subgraph is not connected to
any other node in the same graph so in
this case you see that it's clear that
there are three subgraphs that can be
created
by the connected components algorithm
we now
go a step further and we are now going
to apply hierarchical clustering to
obtain the clusters and the clusters are
then the final deduplication results so
here we see the we see two of the three
graphs from the previous slide
on the left side you see all the banco
cases so these are two companies bangkok
bilbao and balcon there
and as you can see here you see the the
dendrogram of the hierarch clustering
the
that algorithm is able to distinguish
based on the probabilities in the graph
which
representations belong to the same
company and which belong to a different
company
and the value of hierarchical clustering
becomes more apparent if you look to the
the graph on the right
there are three different companies
deutsche bursa deutsche post deutsche
telekom
and as you can see
there are large probabilities like this
0.78.87
between instances from deutsche post and
from deutsche bar version so that means
that the classifier basically would say
this is a match
but because we have a graph because we
have a network with all the
probabilities in it
the hierarchical clustering
takes into account also these cases
these edges with very low probabilities
and thereby creates clusters of the
things that are
that belong to the same entity
so this really shows the value of
of a hierarchical clustering
because the classifier on its own would
say that this is a match
so i would say let's have a look at the
demo let's have a look at the code and
see how the duplicate works
um the dupli by is
obviously hosted on github so you can
clone it there and you can
look at the example notebooks
dedupli is shipped with
two datasets we now look at the voters
data that you saw earlier
here are again the name the suburb and
the postcode
columns
and we are now going to
create a deduplication instance and we
are going to provide some advanced
settings the simple case without with
out of the box mode so to say you can
you can try yourself but i can show you
how to do this some more advanced
settings
let's say that we want to choose the
similarity metrics ourselves per column
that we want to apply
um
let's say so from fuzzywessie we import
some of the
string similarity metrics that you can
find there and we create a dict that we
call field info and for every column so
name suburb and postcode the three
columns in our data set
we enter a list of the functions that we
want to use to compare those those
strings
let's also say that we want to define
the blocking rules ourselves
and let's say we are not interested in
blocking rules
that
apply to suburban postcodes we only want
to apply blocking rules to the name
column and let's say we want we only
want to see the first two characters
this this can be useful in some cases if
you have very small data you probably
want to have you don't bother about
blocks being too large
on the other hand if you have very large
data you do want to have your blocks a
bit confined
so this is something you can play with
if you run into troubles on
on your particular use case
so furthermore we say interaction is
true so that basically means that you
want to include interaction features
between the columns of your data set and
what happens under the hood what i
showed you earlier is that scikit-learn
then includes the product of all the
string similarity metrics so for example
partial ratio on the name times token
set ratio suburb
and as i said when we use these
interaction features then the logistic
regression classifier applies l1
regularization
furthermore we set verbosity to want to
get some more information during the
process
and we create the deduplicator instance
with the things that we defined before
and then during fitting the actual
active learning starts
the
the
sample is created under the hood
and we get presented the cases that we
need to label
so here we see we need to answer yes or
no
whether this pair is a match so you have
name one shipper one postcode one name
two suburb two and post code two for
rebecca bauer bond
the first three cases are always perfect
matches can we do that to help the
active learner package to
have a
good start
here we see rebecca barbond and derrick
brewery that is obviously not a match
not a match
and if you continue over time you see
already right now after only six
labels
that um the case that is presented here
is already
they are already much closer right this
shelby and xiaomi is sort of similar
the suburb is the same and the postcode
is also the same
um
but
yeah it must be a typo so i guess this
is a match
willie green and william reynolds
let me continue a few cases more
and as you can see after a while you get
information on the uncertainty so the
last uncertainty improvement that you
see here that is basically the biggest
uncertainty improvement that you saw
during the last i think five iterations
and the uncertainty is just uncertainty
as i explained in the slides let me
label a few more
no match
i think this will be a match right
robert smith roberta smith
there we go
no match
okay so if you continue a bit more then
you will get the message that the model
has converged because the uncertainty is
not improving anymore or because the
uncertainty drops below 0.1
but let's say for the sake of time we
are finished
and what happens now is that you get a
score histogram and this these are the
scores that are calculated on the data
in your sample that you didn't use for
training
so obviously the majority of the scores
are very low because the majority of the
pairs are not mesh
then in the middle region of the scores
there's nothing and that's also logical
because otherwise there would be
presented by the active learning package
and then you see a few cases that have a
large score and these are most likely
the duplicates
so the active learning is finished the
blocking rules are found in this case
that's the the first two characters of
the name but that is trivial because
that's the one that we defined here and
we only presented one
blocking rule to the to the user
to the to the package
so then we have our trained duplicator
instance
and then we can use it to predict it on
our data that we have here or now on new
data
and what we can now do is we can say
well the majority of these these scores
these very low scores they will not end
up in the same cluster it is not really
likely that a 0.05
probability of a pair will belong to the
same company so what we can say and
that's useful especially if you work
with large data is that you put a
threshold on the similarity probability
of in this case 0.1
and that can make the computations much
faster because there are just fewer
computations to make
so here we see the results
we have in our original data frame still
the columns name suburban postcodes but
now we have an additional column that's
called deduplication id
and that basically gives a number to all
the rows that belong to the same entity
in this case the same person
as you can see lucille richards is has
the same the duplication id
uh luther baldwin same story
and then here we have even a case with
three
yeah rows that belong to the same person
so the deduplication id number itself is
meaningless but it's really about uh
which rows have the same number
well we we now applied it on the data
that we trained it on but you can also
save your duplicator instance using
tickle and
load it again from this
and apply it to data and you will get
exactly the same result
so this is in a nutshell how it works
you can have a further look in the
notebooks that are on github
and let me then go back to the
presentation
so this was the the presentation of the
dupli by
package for deduplication
i have more ideas to further develop the
package i would like to test
neural networks instead of the
classification the logistic regression
classifier
and you can basically follow their work
already on the in one of the branches
but i'm very open to ideas from the
pi data community so please feel free to
contribute you can find the address here
on on github
and
i'm happy to take any questions now
um thank you so much fitz uh we have a
couple of questions here
um
the first question i will read
is from mark andre
mcandre asks is it possible to also get
uh the uncertainty for each to do the
duplication id
yeah no that's not implemented um so uh
what you
what you can set and i didn't discuss
that here you can set thresholds for the
for the clustering
um and thereby you can increase the
recall or the or or the precision yeah
depending on if you increase the
threshold or lower it but the
uncertainty so basically the quality of
the of the cluster that is not given no
but i'm looking forward to a pull
request for that
okay thank you so much
we also have another question from
akiona i can ask is it possible to
customize presentation of user decisions
to make it easier to compare
you mean
the representation or in the notebook
where you see the the pairs
um
again i'm open for other ideas what you
could do i saw there's a new package
that's that's also dealing with
similarities simcity is called
and the the the one who developed that
uses pigeon for in jupiter notebooks uh
if you use something like that it seems
more more user-friendly it looks nicer
but on the other hand it doesn't then
work from the comment line um but yeah
you could definitely uh
yeah propose something
okay uh we have a couple of questions
here but we only have two minutes left
uh
uh one question as uh us is that how do
you train blogging rules at the same
time with similarity scoring or in
active learning
yeah no so i know that there are other
solutions that do it at the same time in
the duplicate i do it as completely
different
independent steps
so it's really first
the blocking is done independently from
the from the scoring
okay thank you and the other question as
is how do you plan to consider the main
knowledge in the media domain knowledge
yeah
yeah yeah i understand
um
[Music]
in the matching algorithm yet so the
domain knowledge is basically implicit
while you are training it
um
so if you that's basically what i showed
here so the domain knowledge in this
case the example that i gave here could
be that i see that a uh
a three could be an e right because
there was some i think ocr errors in the
in the names
so this is basically something you
provide implicitly while training the
ddpi instance
okay
i think we can give them one last
question lucas asks is it possible to
use already labeled data with duplicates
and no duplicates for training
yeah
good question
the the idea behind the duplicate is
it's a very simple
package to easily and quickly get
a deduplication instance that is trained
on active using active hearing there is
no functionality yet to include already
labeled data but i can imagine that that
is valuable on the other hand i have to
say that
normally you get conversions in like
20 or 30 cases so that goes really
quickly
again if you have a pull request i'm
happy to take a look at it but it
shouldn't save you so much time if you
use the
excellent extra clearing as implemented
by modal
okay um thank you so much fritz um i'm
certain if there are any questions left
unanswered they will connect with you on
github and on all your socials
thank you so much
thanks a lot